And then there's other podcasts I listened to,
which was absolutely insane. You know, Keith Morrison
from Dateline dude,
the thing is called there's something about Pam.
Oh, I'm sorry. The thing about Pam and I, I swear,
I just listened to it because of the guy's voice.
The first three episodes were banging. I was like, wait a second.
And then I realized it was maybe just the guy's voice because Keith Morrison
would do the way he does it. First of all, how's his face?
His face it's so long.
It looks like Clint Eastwood is looking at a fun house mirror.
I mean, his face is largely Lima bean,
Keith Lima, bean Morrison, dude.
It's so funny, dude. I was listening to this. First of all,
the first episode I was listening to in Atlantic city as I was going to bed,
I got so creeped out that I had to stop listening to it.
Cause I got scared and my. Yes. Is it all good? Yes.
And Keith Morrison, dude, just he's this guy.
One close to the case, obviously,
you know the thing about Pam that was brought to you by Dateline NBC
from Dateline, NBC, Kathy singer and Christine films. Right.
But the thing about Pam, you know,
love by the way, to Pam. That's how he's saying it.
I know more about Pam.
I know more about Pam than any of you know about Pam.
I mean sings it here. Hold on. Just listen. God is,
I don't know. Who's better. The guy from forensic file or is it okay for real.
5:00 PM then he ran errands for the next hour. Filled up.
His tank picked up cigarettes, dog food, couple of ice teas.
He got to Mike's house for game night, about 6:00 PM.
Let me just show you that. I'll show you that part.
Opt at Arby's and drove 30 or so more minutes to get home clocking
his arrival. Uh, nine 49 45. Okay. It's all good.
According to official records,
Russ made that night approximately 900.
Okay. She's going through the, Oh,
it got a little bit dark with it at nine 30 that night. No checked out.
But you could tell that something wasn't sitting right. Detective
Russ made that nine one one call at approximately nine 40.
So his story checked out. Oh,
but you could tell that something wasn't sitting right with detectives.
So good. But you could towel something.
Wasn't sitting right with detective dude.
I got to find a good.
Uniforms. CSI detectives. I mean.
There was one part where I took a screenshot of it.
Let me go get it because it was so funny the way he said, he says Pam,
ah, Oh, here it is.
Pam it's episode three at five.
This is the I do. What an idiot. You know, I was like, Oh,
got to the way he says the way he says.
He hears all of the evidence.
This guy, you can just hear, you get so mad. He punches.
And by all the evidence,
he meant really everything to do with cam.
And by all the evidence, human, everything to do with
power.
Wow.
I love going to dig into all that ball battery in this country
that can, can take Russ.
I got to play that again by all the evidence you meant really
everything to do with Pam. Ah,
free letters.
The guy goes Pam. Oh,
they'll balls on Keith Morrison. See that's the thing, dude. God is good.
And of course there were things about Pam that we didn't know about.
When, when we figured it out, we learned that there was more than meets the eye.
With all these inconsistencies.
Joel decided to look for other possible holes in the prosecution's case,
Mike, that polygraph test.
God, I want to hang with this guy. I mean,
imagine just chilling with the dude.
Just like going to get some food.
Careful.
There's a yellow light and it might turn red
before you cross the line. You'd just be like,
that's so interesting.
Oh the air bag burst it out.
You might want to watch out. There's a sharp part.
There's a sharp metal slab coming out where used to be the door.
Oh, he caught himself.
My favorite is when it gets real like chilled and like, um,
um, con comfy with it. No, of course.
That's what Pam would've said,
Pam. Uh. I love that.
Guy's voice.
I don't know if it's him or the other forensic file guys. That's the.
How's the forensic guy. Fast guy go again. Uh, there was Oh yeah.
Yeah. That's how it is. Um,
let me just play a little bit. That makes me laugh so hard. That was of course.
W what was the guy's name is the voice, right? Forensic
files, voice the voice,
the voice voice guy.
I mean, you know, Oh, the behind the scenes really
forensic files has always differed from other true crime teams.
Take files as a film.
Once an episode is edited, it's sent to the Los Angeles based music collection.
It's a very different thing.
The music really drives the all right. We know here's the guy, here's the voice.
Hello? It's so time about that. I,
my time in the army, and then I got into radio in 55,
but here you are on the CBS morning show in New York. And it was,
you were doing the land. And that was.
And the you'd see the engineer there just before we start put that diamond
cutter on the disc and they would give you the cue. And the,
I remember the orchestra would go for us. A tick tock,
tick tock does the Hamilton watch company and then music.
And I would come on and say, the passage of time is beyond our control,
but it passes beautifully. When a Hamilton and Mark CR, then they would,
the girl was saying, was it a dream? Was it a dream?
Did you have time? Oh, this is a tribute.
If you ain't, if you don't have to tribute on honor,
Thomas was born in Pensacola,
Florida on June 28th, 1924. I mean, imagine like,
you know, if you, if you don't have a tribute on YouTube, you ain't.
There's a tribute for everyone. I swear to God, there's a tribute for my maid.
That comes, it'll be like
24, the son of a Welsh minister.
I love who does this voice from them. How to communicate.
He's probably so nervous. Cause he was doing the tribute to the guy. Who's the,
Peter Thomas,
his voice is good too checked and enunciate every night,
growing up, Peter read stories aloud to his family. That's,
which perfected his technique that didn't happen to his father's philosophy.
Words must be visualized,
understood and felt before spoken. Well,
imagine thinking that,
imagine that what a you'd be
succinylcholine.
There were trace amounts of succinylcholine words must be
visualized, understood and felt before spoken.
Pam
words must be visualized or understood and felt before I spoke.
And um, but yeah, it's so crazy though. The lady,
I want to talk about that way too long, but there was a lady, um, that was, um,
there was a lady that, uh, this guy got,
uh, wrongly accused of killing his wife. Imagine you,
your wife gets killed and then you get thrown in jail and you didn't do it.
Are you kidding me, dude? There would nothing would be worse than that.
Like, well of course, nothing will be worse than that,
but like to add insult to injury,
I don't understand how these people like stay on in the courtroom and they're
just like silent dude. Yeah. It'd be like, Hey, you. I didn't do it.
Why is he asking that question? And they'd be like, contempt, contempt, hostile,
witness, hostile a diff whatever the I am person on trial.
I'd be like, dude, I didn't do it. I didn't do it. And they'd be like, well,
this is what she, this is his. He goes crazy. See this one? I'm like, no,
you don't understand, man. There's a real killer out there.
That's getting away with it. I didn't do it. I loved her cases. Open dude,
go find it. I'd be in jail so quick.
Let me tell you that right now my wife died.
I'd be in jail so quick because I would, I would show so much anger.
I'd be like, you're not doing it. Right, dude,
the cops would show up and they'd be like, okay. I was right here, dude.
All right. I wasn't here obviously when she got killed and then now I'm here.
So what's up dude? And they'd be like, Whoa, Whoa, Mr. Dalea Whoa,
did you guys ever fight? And I'd be like, I'm course. We did.
We're married to each other. And they'd be like, dude,
okay, we're going to have to take you in. And they'll be like me.
I didn't do it. Get the real bad guy out there. Coppers.
I'd be in jail. Immediately.
Podcasts about me called the thing about Chris.
The thing about Chris is he got so mad when the police officers
showed up because he thought the cops, Warren doing the job,
Mel naturally,
Chris got a little frustrated and he swung at the cop and the cop
who is
very well-trained duct and then put Chris's arm behind his back,
put the handcuffs. And then Chris went to jail for the rest of his life.
Screamed every day.
No, that's the thing, dude,
you could kill my wife and I would get blamed for it. No doubt.
There's no doubt. I wouldn't get blamed for it. And I'll never do that.
I would never kill my wife. I would never kill my wife.
Anyway.